نحن الحقيقه
كنا من المسرورين بهذا الاتفاق
ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى
ان يتم سرورنا بتنفيذه
وعوده الامور الى طبيعتها بين دوله ايران
وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وبين ايران والمنطقه عموما نحن كنا من
الدعاه يعني قديما
الى ان تكون ايران مصدر طمانينه لجيرانها
من العرب
وبذلك
يعني تفتح
هذه المنطقه منطقه الخليج
بوابه ايران على العالم العربي ولا يوجد
من جيرانها من يشكل تهديدا لها لكن
هل له اصل بالنسبه لهذا لايران اليوم هذا
الاتفاق يعني بناء على ماذا تم في وجهه
نظر النظام الايراني برايك
يعني انا اعتقد ان ايران اقتنعت بانه لابد
من عوده الامور الى طبيعتها مع جيرانها
مقدمه الى دخولها في المنظومه الدوليه
وعوده العلاقات الى المجتمع الدولي من
خلال هذه التجربه التي نامل نجاحها
وادركت ايران بان السياسه التي اعتمدت
يعني في العقود الماضيه هي سياسه
يعني ادت الى
مشاكل لها مع العالم ومع محيطها وفي
الداخل ايضا
ونامل يعني ان تكون هذه هي
الاسباب التي
ادت الى تسريع مثل هذا الاتفاق بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران